- HE JUST SEEMS REALLY DISTANT,
AND HE'S ALWAYS ON THE PHONE
WITH SOMEONE OR MAKING PLANS.
HE CHANGED HIS EMAIL PASSWORD,
WHICH SEEMS REALLY SUSPICIOUS.
I CALLED BOBBY,
AND I ASKED HIM TO HELP ME OUT.
- I'M ROBERT BRUSCHA,
AKA BOBBY BOTTLESERVICE,
AKA BOBBY BOTTLESERVICE.
I WILL MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE PROTECTED,
WHATEVER HAPPENS HERE, OKAY?
I TREAT WOMEN WITH RESPECT,
BECAUSE, NO DISRESPECT,
THERE'S NOTHING MORE BEAUTIFUL
THAN A WOMAN IN NEED.
BECAUSE MY MOTHER
RAISED ME RIGHT.
AND WHEN MY FATHER CHEATED--
WHEN MY FATHER CHEAT--
I REPLAYED IT IN MY HEAD
OVER AND OVER.
[muttering angrily]
- THANK YOU.
- OKAY.
- GOD, YOU SMELL AMAZING.
- THANKS, BOBBY.
- DID YOU EAT AN ORANGE
BEFORE THIS?
- I JUST TO FIND OUT
WHAT'S GOING ON.
I MEAN, I'VE BEEN GETTING SICK
OVER IT BECAUSE I--
- OKAY, SHUT UP.
I JUST GOT A TEXT MESSAGE.
IT'S FROM PETER PAPARAZZO.
THE DEAL'S GOING DOWN.
WHAT'S UP, BUSINESS ASSOCIATE?
- YO, BRO, CHECK IT.
CHEATER, CHEATER, CHEATER,
ALL OVER THE PLACE.
- IT'S TIME TO BUST
SOME SKULLS, 'KAY.
- LET'S KILL IT.
- YEAH, BRO.
OKAY, WHAT'S GOING ON HERE NOW?
ARE YOU CHEATIN'?
- NO, IT'S A BUSINESS COLLEAGUE.
- WORD UP, DUDE. NICE.
- GOOD STUFF, BRO.
- I'M LOST.
- YOU'RE ON THE SHOW CHEATIN'.
- YOU'RE CHEATING.
- YEAH.
- NICE JOB.
- SO IT'S A GOOD THING?
- YEAH, BRO.
- EVERYBODY DOES THIS, MAN.
JFK, NEWT GINGRICH, SHAGGY.
- EVERYBODY.
- THAT'S SMART.
- MAYBE WE'LL DO SOME SHOTS
TO BRING HOME.
PROM PICTURES.
- YEAH.
- ALL RIGHT,
HOW ABOUT SOME PICTURES?
- SAY "LANCE ARMSTRONG."
- LANCE ARMSTRONG.
- YEAH.
- SAY HI TO YOUR WIFE.
- HI, HONEY.
- DOES ANYONE HAVE AN EXTRA
JACKET OR ANYTHING?
IT'S KIND OF COLD OUT HERE.
- I GOT TO BREAK IT DOWN, BRO.
HOW DO YOU DO IT?
WHAT'S THE SECRET?
- I APPRECIATE YOU ASKING
BECAUSE MOST PEOPLE DON'T
RESPECT IT QUITE AS MUCH
AS YOU DO.
THE LEG WORK IS EXHAUSTING.
- YEAH.
- I HAVE TWO NAMES...LEGALLY.
- REALLY?
WHAT DO YOU GO BY?
STEVE AND TIM.
- STEVE AND TIM. I ALTERNATE.
- OKAY.
DO YOU BUY HER NICE STUFF,
OR ARE YOU JUST, LIKE,
"FLIP OVER, WEIRDO?"
- I'VE NEVER SAID, "FLIP OVER,
WEIRDO," TO ANYONE.
- SURE.
NOW, DO YOU HAVE CHILDREN
THAT WOULD MAKE THIS
MORE TERRIBLE?
- NOT THAT I ACKNOWLEDGE.
- OOH.
- WOW. OH.
- WHO IS THIS BITCH, HUH?
IS THIS THE BITCH THAT YOU'RE
CHEATING ON ME WITH?
- NO, THIS IS MY GIRLFRIEND
WHO I'M WITH.
RIGHT, SWEETIE?
- WHAT?
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
- NO, LET ME EXPLAIN.
- YOU DON'T SPEAK.
- LET ME EXPLAIN.
- STOP TALKING.
YOU DON'T SPEAK EITHER.
YOU...SPEAK.
- SHE'S VERY MUCH IDENTIFIED
THE WEAK LINK HERE.
- I'M GAY.
- LET'S SIT DOWN.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS, OKAY?
- THEY'RE TOGETHER.
- NO.
- ARE YOU VICKY, HUH?
- LET ME EXPLAIN
WHAT'S OCCURRED HERE.
THIS GUY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
WRONG, OKAY?
I'M DATING VICKY,
VERY MUCH SERIOUSLY.
BUT I ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER LADY, OKAY?
I'M THE CHEATER.
TIM HERE, AKA STEVE--
- I GO BY BOTH.
- THIS GUY'S A GODDAMN
CHIVALROUS FRIEND OF MINE
WHO STEPPED UP TO THE PLATE WHEN
I NEEDED HIM MOST SO THAT I CAN
HAVE UNPROTECTED SEX
WITH THIS FOREIGN PERSON.
LET'S GO OUTSIDE AND DO ORAL,
AND I'LL FEEL VERY MUCH GUILTY
ABOUT IT.
- YES, BABY, LET'S GO.
- OKAY.
- COME ON.
LET'S GO.
- THAT EXPLAINS THAT.